Do you remember when we all
had to stop the spread and stay at home?
Well, I tell you, one of the unexpected,
positive things
to come out of that time --
well, other than the normalization
of comfortable clothing in public,
obviously --
(Laughter)
was that my industry, digital art
and immersive entertainment,
experienced a huge surge of interest.
More folks than ever before
turned to their screens
to seek out digital experiences
and online connection
and well, social connection
in online spaces.
We couldn't connect in-person,
so suddenly, our digital lives took on
a whole new level of importance.
This sudden global demand
accelerated the research and development
of a previously sci-fi concept
known as the metaverse.
In the metaverse, we will connect
with one another as virtual avatars.
We will live, work and play together,
building a whole new,
magical dimension of existence.
(Laughter)
It sounds like a dream, right?
Well, technically,
it’s a programmer’s nightmare.
But if we can pull it off,
it will become the world's
largest community-driven
digital world-building experiment to date.
But we don't want to sit inside
staring at our screens anymore.
At least I don't.
I love my digital art,
but I want to take it with me
out into the real world.
So let's do that.
This is (Never) Lonely Boy.
He's sitting in the abandoned
lot by himself,
until he's surrounded
by his virtual friends.
Now, what if those virtual friends
could join me here on the TED stage?
(Audience cheers)
Oh, bam!
Hey, little buddies.
Now, ideally, we'd all be wearing
augmented reality glasses,
but consumer-ready AR glasses
are not quite there yet,
but this is kind of cool.
But how can we build on this?
You know, what's next?
And is there a way for the digital
experiences that we create
to truly enrich our physical lives?
So today I'll propose three pillars,
for what I think will help us build
a healthy metaverse.
Starting off with pillar
number one: community.
So back in 2010,
I had a very enriching experience
when I got to collaborate
with a bunch of geniuses
in the Pilbara desert
in northern western Australia.
Meet the Love Punks.
So we went about our digital
world-building in a very analog way.
We got dressed up,
we put on a face paint,
we built sets,
and then we brainstormed
our stories by acting them out.
Now, what blew my mind was how invested
these young people became
in their digital identities
and their digital world-building,
that it motivated them
to show up every single day,
for two years,
to learn how to color
themselves in the comic
and animate themselves in the video game.
Now, the Love Punks
began as a collaboration
with a community of around
40 people and five grandmas.
There was --
Grandmas, they were the wildest punks.
(Laughter)
And in Australia,
they went on to inspire
a live-action TV series
and a national curriculum
teaching young Australians
how to become Love Punks.
(Applause)
It's not bad for a bunch of punks.
So that experience highlighted to me
how the digital worlds we build
can be a wonderful playground
for exploring identity,
for learning new skills,
for practicing creativity
and bringing our communities together.
And that brings us to pillar number two:
technology
and more specifically,
access to technology.
We need to ensure everyone can participate
in this future metaverse.
So around the same time as Love Punks,
I began imagining how to scale
these digital world-building ideas
in my cyberpunk web comic called Nawlz.
Now I imagined, like,
a future digital culture
where the youth had chips in their head
that allowed them to project
their art and imagination
onto a shared digital layer
that covered themselves
and their city.
So like,
they could hang out at the club
wearing their virtual fashion.
Or they could get chased down the street
by some crazy digital tentacle
things that got pretty weird.
That digital culture
would be described today
as an augmented reality metaverse.
Now we're probably not all ready
to get chips in our heads,
but thankfully we can access
augmented reality on our mobile devices.
So one day I received
a mysterious comment on that web comic.
It read:
"We could make some of those things ..."
Very mysterious.
So I clicked on the user profile
and discovered that person
was an augmented reality programmer.
So I messaged them back immediately:
"Yes" Let's make all the things!!!"
That person, Lukasz Karluk
is now my business partner,
and we augmented everything.
Augmented reality comics,
augmented reality tattoos, stickers.
There's a cute little turtle.
Kids could color in their own kites
and then fly them immediately
as augmented reality kites.
I even AI hacked "The New York Times."
That was a little controversial.
(Laughter)
We had a lot of artists
reaching out to us,
asking how we were doing it.
So we created tools to allow them
to augment their work.
And very quickly,
we had a community of artists
covering the world
with their augmented art.
It was beautiful.
I felt like my vision was finally
starting to make some traction.
But up until now,
all the experiences that I've shared
have been standalone.
For example, a Love Punk's avatar
kind of like step out of the video game
and then suddenly appear
walking down the street
beside you in augmented reality?
Like, that digital bridge
doesn't exist yet.
But what if it did?
And this brings me to my third pillar:
decentralization.
So for us to move seamlessly
through the metaverse,
we need for our art and our avatars
to be decentralized.
We can't be dependent
on a single platform.
Sorry, Zuck.
(Laughs)
I mean, what if that platform were to die?
We don't want to lose our art.
So NFTs --
another word that's been
flying around a lot lately --
help us to solve this problem.
NFTs are unique,
decentralized digital assets,
and they've also come
to represent a new economy
that has been widely accepted
as the norm for buying
and selling digital art.
So not only can NFTs move
from one platform to the next,
but they can be sold
and digital artists can get paid.
And that all helps to keep
the lights on in the metaverse.
So lately I've been kicking the wheels
of my own metaverse
called the Sutuverse.
Very humble.
And my first project
in the Sutuverse is Neonz.
I illustrated hundreds
of cyberpunk characteristics
like virtual reality headsets
and face tattoos and antennas.
Then we created a tool to combine
all these characteristics together
to generate 10,000 unique avatars
as NFT artworks.
We then put those NFT artworks up
on the environmentally friendly
Tezos blockchain.
Thousands of fellow cyberpunk
enthusiasts collected them.
Thank you.
We then connected our augmented
reality app to that blockchain
to allow our community
to become their Neonz in AR.
And look at us.
We're like a cyberpunk Brady Bunch.
And just imagine again, when we have
those augmented reality glasses
and we can just see each other
down the pub like this,
like, that'll be one
hell of a Neonz reunion.
If you're not interested in the theatrics
of putting Neonz on your face,
that's cool.
Because you can also put your Neonz
floating out there in the physical world.
So there's some Neonz down in the snow,
Neonz down the beach,
Neonz floating above an oblivious cat.
And if you're not interested
in the Neonz aesthetic, that's fine, too,
because soon you'll be able to put any
digital art you've created or collected
floating out there in the physical world.
So I feel like
our Love Punks community
and our Neonz community
are totally ready for this future.
But how are you folks feeling?
(Cheers)
Are you ready for this brave
new digital world?
(Audience murmurs)
Not sure?
Well, this is just the beginning.
You could leave a digital artwork
on the street corner
for your lover to find.
You could reinvent your backyard
with an animated treasure hunt
for your kids and their friends.
We could use this tool
to simply cover the world.
Or we could use it to further
connect us to this world.
I'm interested in the latter.
How can we use this powerful tool
to create an augmented reality metaverse
that truly enriches our physical lives?
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)